[Music]
welcome another exciting episode of Cal
West and today I bring you
sideshows gladiator halt maquette this
statue was here I didn't even think that
we was going to get another gladiator
halt but I am pleased that we did it
now let me give you the synapses of
Blatter at all if from the Planet Hulk
storyline where the Hulk is jettison
from Earth from his friends to a remote
planet and is actually the wrong planet
that he goes to when he gets to this
planet he is held as a golden one like
the prophesized month and he gets there
but he is captured by the Red King and
he is enslaved and he is forced to fight
in a gladiator arena now in this arena
he fights different characters he joins
up what a band of gladiators they
overthrow the government and falls on
love and bad things happen to the whole
that makes the halt come back and then
you get the next storyline which is
world war hulk which is probably my best
storyline the long side of the planet
hall playing a hook sets it up world war
hulk finishes it and it's a great lead
if you haven't read it yet
but let's get into the statute first
this statute came in to shipper boxes
and the shipper boxes one has the base
one has the body very heavy what I don't
like is the shipper boxes didn't have
any art prints right usually you have
the box the art box and then the phone
statue boom
not this one half in the same way with
the juggernut but you did get a detailed
art print with instructions on how to
put this statue together and that was
definitely needed here because the base
is as elaborate as the statute itself
and it is heavy the level of detail that
has gone into the base alone the spider
type creature that he is battling on the
textures the skin texture of the cause
the spikes the eyes the teeth everything
of this base even the mud that they're
in is incredible then you get to the
statue itself which has to switch out
heads so not like the first sexual that
I had this statue has two heads one with
the gladiator helmet on one with the
gladiator helmet balls and I'm still
struggling on which one I'm gonna um the
tick because both of them are incredible
the detail to the pupils and the eyes
which has a greenish to it of the lips
every level of detail that you can
imagine scishow spread no expense I
think they were out to prove a point to
the statue world
with this statute and I think that point
has come across because every stitching
looks real the metal looks like metal
the leather looks like leather the skin
looks like skin
it's an incredible statue from top to
bottom well this is the part of the
video where I'm gonna tell you like
following subscribe and also go to Lords
of gaminguys net where you can get a ton
of opinion pieces a lot of reviews with
Lord addict playing these hard games I
know he's playing Final Fantasy 7 remake
right now and he probably ended the game
three or four times he's probably
playing it on super hard right now
so look for those videos also look for
old episodes of Kos and the last word
with low tide new line of artists there
our head giving you the greatest
information but what what a lot cause
when you hold it the best damn destiny
podcast on YouTube
Bar None and those are facts
so listen stick around continue to watch
the video as you can see the detail
unboxing of this statute and also when
you go to laws again with that neck the
dimensions and synapsis of this statue
is there so you can always check that
out you always see if the statute fits
in your budget and it's 1,400 I believe
and you can also see if it fits in your
cabinets things and you know also weight
wise alright so see you next week when I
bring something incredible
stay close
[Music]